hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen wie heute zu einem neuen
video falls ihr euch jetzt schon fragt
okay ist an neben intro irgend ich bin
tot mister lu hat mich getötet
mister nur mist an lud zum zweiten mal
wieso heißt er ist dann nur weil er so
gut ist also freunde falls euch jetzt
schon fragt ob im schnitt gerade
irgendetwas anders ist und ob ihr euch
fragte hey ist wirklich von luca
geschnitten worden
nee ist es nicht das video wurde nämlich
von einem kumpel von mir namens um
mitgeschnitten
ich habe mir nämlich gedacht ich bin im
urlaub und wollte eigentlich videos
vorproduzieren für jeden tag unten paten
gesagt dass voll blöd dass nicht so viel
gaming vor produziert wird von dir und
so macht doch mal ein bisschen mehr
gaming gaming gaming gaming und ich
dachte ja okay ich hab ein kumpel der
schneidet auch recht gern videos und ich
lasse ihnen einfach mal ein video von
mir schneiden und ich wollte jetzt nicht
so tun von wegen ja okay es ist nicht
von mir mich ich glaub ich will jetzt
hier ein ja oder auch nicht ok ich hab'
ich hoffe dass alles gut so jetzt guck
mal ganz kurz da kommt einer hoch die
ich habe ich auch getötet okay jetzt
lege ich mich mal hier weil da comdirect
safe noch einmal hin erst mal eine
granate ist keiner gucken ist keiner
ich bin profi viele meinten auf jeden
fall sie wollten mir gaming sehen das
schaffe ich es zeitlich nicht mit dem
four produzieren weil ich ja irgendwie
ein paar tage auf dem festival war da
noch ein bisschen unterwegs in der
weltgeschichte und halt auch noch videos
vorproduzieren muss deswegen habe jetzt
einfach ein kumpel gefragt so bock ein
video von mir zu schneiden und er meinte
ja kann es mal probieren kann es
natürlich nicht genau so machen wie ich
aber er wird sich daran orientieren und
versuchen einfach dieses video irgendwie
hin zu schneiden also das video hier
jetzt nicht von mir geschnitten sondern
von einem kumpel also wundert euch nicht
ich glaube irgendwie immer komplett
andere wege als alle leute mit denen ich
irgendwie zusammen spieler aber da vorne
okay das war übrigens auch man ja okay
ich lag mit motto wir laufen hier
einfach mal den kollegen so ein bisschen
hinterher ich weiß nicht ich kann halt
nicht den weg aber der wie heißt der
doppel in der kennt bestimmt wer weiß wo
wir dann der ist gut
er tötet jetzt jemanden stark gemacht
ich schmeiße da mal ne granate hin und
schaue ob da auch dazu niemand dann
hoffe ich mal hier links lang und schaut
hier jemand ist weil ja vielleicht
gesehen haben
hier links ist jemand gesponnen
das heißt ich schaue mal
er steht dort immer noch drin warum kann
ich nicht einfach mal gegner finden die
so schlecht sind wie ich das kann doch
nicht so schwer sein freunde hier hinten
sollte ein paar gegner sein das heißt
ich schaue einfach mal ob hier jemand
ist den ich kenne beziehungsweise den
ich nicht kenne sondern ein gegner von
mir ist nämlich wieder vorne ist das
budget badge halo ist hier jemand wegen
wenig töten kann sowieso so der es total
abwegig war im chat gehabt wenn wir auf
den table gucken wie ich den letzter ich
hab eine bessere kg als die andere
hälfte bei mir glaube ich
das board kam für drei minuten und ich
bin so schlecht zu christkindlmarkt
also ich kann es irgendwie verstehen
dass ich letzter bin weil ich bin halt
echt nicht gut aber ich verstehe es
nicht wie ich so schlecht sein kann also
ok spieler spiel so alle drei wochen mal
irgendwie oder so aber von dem typ der
sich hinter einer säule versteckt es
gibt nur einen menschen auf denen sie
abgesehen hat und das ist mir egal wer
sich freut mich grad hinlegen kallir ich
habe sieben getötet sieben mal gestorben
also ein sack a d das ist der letzte
kill hier ich würde sagen wir haben noch
eine runde dran
die nächste runde geht los meine damen
und herren ich laufen komplett anderen
weg als mama oma da laufe ich los und
kriegt direkt ne scheiße kacke geworfen
hier kommt her freunde
oh mein gott okay ich hab denen ich den
zweiten doppel
ich bin erst da ich bin erster meine
damen und herren es geht jetzt gab es
schon richtig ab dahin ist noch einer da
sind wir direkt erster ich habe drei
kills meine damen und herren ok alles
super hier sollten sie gehen mit einer
rauslaufen komme ich bin über den
adrenalin hey er gut dann ist er jetzt
weg jawohl abgeschossen von ihm ich
überleg mal okay haben wir ihn hier so
direkt erst ab 40 meine damen und herren
so muss es nämlich laufen so läuft
ziemlich ab wenn luca hier in einem
spiel ist so als habe ich für der
scheiße so läuft eigentlich nie ab misst
anubis diesmal meinem team
dem müssen wir hinterher eine neue
taktik ist einfach diesem dem oder
vorgehen zu lassen der ist nicht gut
sondern nur
vorletzter das heißt wenn er irgendwo
von wem getötet wird kann es ein vorteil
für mich sein da muss einer rauskommen
dann muss einer rauskommen da viele
leute würden jetzt vielleicht sagen okay
der kämpft oder so aber ich würde sagen
ich bin einfach nur ein aufmerksamer
spieler der genau beobachtet wann wo
leute vielleicht sein könnten
ja man ein alter blöde kenne jene
granaten um zu gucken ob da einer ist da
ist niemand
jetzt da hinten noch mal mit semtex
hingeworfen und da hinten einer chill da
als mister loop okay ich hab ihr mann
getroffen
erstmals führten wir dichter vorne genau
und jetzt habe ich nämlich hiervon nur
noch jemanden getroffen der da vorne
steht da haben wir ihnen weg ich bin
wieder zweiter mit 9 zu 3 kg da müssten
jetzt gleich leute raus kommen genau da
sind welche 1up faktisch haben
mitgekriegt ich bin da wieder hin
ich will dahin ich will mich recht nicht
mag die nicht irgendwann ist ende im
gelände lassen typ
ein zweiter komme schon da ist doch der
alles hilft warum bin ich dich erst da
safe kommen da welche raus ich schwöre
euch das nummer eins li xin was ist er
denn von larry macht das stark kalibers
zu stark okay da haben wir ihnen da
hinten kommen noch jemand habe ich
gesehen was will er denn schon wieder
hier
du stirbst doch auch mister lu bei den
letzten kill gemacht wir haben schon
wieder gewonnen 75 zu 54 ich habe eine
kg von 14 zu fünf ist diesmal ein
bisschen besser gewesen auch nicht
perfekt aber fünften für mich geht's
klar an dieser stelle will ich das
wieder werden meine damen herren wenn es
euch gefallen will ich bei der bewertung
freuen wie schon zu beginn gesagt das
video wurde nicht von mir geschnitten
sondern von meinem kumpel me to me
tender dass sie gerade beschnitt hey ich
werde so was nicht oft machen also das
ist das allererste mal dass wirklich ein
video auf einem kanal was ich
aufgenommen habe nicht auch von mir
selbst geschnitten wurde
ich hoffe es hat euch vielleicht
trotzdem bisschen gefallen ich habe nur
gedacht okay heute würde sonst gar
nichts kommen weiter gerade im urlaub
wird und dann mach ich doch lieber ein
video was zwar mit mir ist aber nicht
von mir geschnitten anstatt das gar
nichts kommen wenn ihr versteht was ich
meine aber ich glaube jetzt in ruhe
anschauen